phase four and I think we should have
infrastructure and I think we should
have a payroll tax moratorium I mean
there are a lot of people I'm one of
them that would have liked to have seen
the payroll tax cut as a permanent cut
but we should do the double edged
meaning business employee payroll tax
cut so we're talking about that that was
the president yesterday at the White
House talking about the next phase of
opening up our economy which is ready to
go when we're ready to let it go here to
react to that representative Brad
Wenstrup Republican from Ohio member of
the House Intelligence Committee and a
physician also an Iraq war vet himself
congressman thank you so much for being
here this morning we appreciate it
so what is the feel on Capitol Hill
about what should happen next it's got
to pass the house in the Senate the
president clear about what he wants what
should happen I think some things that
we want to do further we've done three
phases of assistance to the American
people and to the whole and fight
against this pandemic as it is in many
ways I want to see the first three
phases roll out successfully and see
where we are with that but there's no
doubt about it for example with the
paycheck protection program we want to
get more to it the president has asked
for that and we want to do that you know
it's been a little challenging obviously
most because we're all working from afar
but we are working and we're trying to
get something done so we'll be glad to
work with the administration and do
what's best for the American people to
get through this and then get our
country back back on track what what's
most likely to pass I mean Nancy Pelosi
has been obstinate she's tried to put
things into the bill that have nothing
to do with recovery what you know when
it comes to a payroll tax holiday and
when it comes to infrastructure when it
comes to staying focused on small
business can that happen do you have
good faith partners on the Democrat side
right now well that's the challenge
right because I don't think we really
did especially in phase three of this
whole process because they were holding
things out delaying the whole process
just for a few lines I mean nothing's
more glaring than the 25 million that
went to the Kennedy Center and I said
unless the Kennedy Center's being
setup is a makeshift hospital for grown
a virus this has no play here but I
think that mrs. Pelosi will try to get
things in and we'll we'll see if we can
stop her I hope we can because there are
things that we have to get done in order
to get through this the president
understands that so hopefully we won't
see further delays from mrs. policy
let's stick to what the problem is at
hand and get aid into the hands of the
American people and so that small
businesses as you mentioned can maintain
themselves not lose employees that's the
key we want them to be able to pay their
bills
don't lose employees and drive on yeah
Congress when you talk about problems
let me take you to a little bit of a
different one and that is the World
Health Organization dr. Ted Rose waits
until March 11th to declare it a world
pandemic after which 4201 people have
already died there's 118 thousand cases
in 114 countries he even has the gall to
pan president chompoo earlier in
February stopped flights from China
which we now know his count saved
countless lives is it time to cut
funding to whu-oh well I think the
president is doing the right thing and
talking about that the World Health
Organization is to be there to be
transparent so that we have facts and we
know what is going on I served on our
Board of Health in Cincinnati you cannot
proceed with taking care of health care
issues if you don't have the facts if
you're twisting the facts if you're in
denial about what's going on that's a
problem and what's curious i and some of
my medical colleagues have done a lot of
research on everything is taking place
what's being done in China if you look
at the medical research you can tell
that they knew something big was going
on earlier than they've ever admitted to
so on the medical side it seems that
there was some transparency but on the
political side and on the government
side obviously not and there seems to be
connections trying to play this down you
know you saw the World Health
Organization actually speak out at one
point and say they didn't want a travel
ban why would you do that the numbers
you know have to be real you have to
know exactly what's going on if if the
United States and the rest of the world
are going to respond appropriately so
from here on out I think you know we're
acting on our own we got to get through
this pandemic ourselves and our medical
community along with our government is
doing a great job I think of that but
boy this could have been a whole lot
worse had the president not acted and I
think that the wao has a lot of
explaining to do and I know that this
president will press on that and we as
members of Congress should absolutely
it's got to be an open and honest
transparent
situation or we're going to fail yeah I
mean the American people deserve you
know honest and transparent all of those
things that you mentioned let's talk
about plasma right now because we know
blood banks are playing that they need
those plasma donations the FDA backs the
effort to develop covin 19 treatment
from the plasma of recovered patients we
were talking to one of our medical
doctors dr. Nicole sapphire earlier this
morning about how important the plasma
is going to be in addition to those
antibody tests so where are we with that
right now well I think it's moving right
along the bottom line is we're going to
need donors right and I think dr.
sapphire by the way did a phenomenal job
explaining that today this is one way of
finding out if people had the virus and
got better so that can be peace of mind
for them they can return to the work
force but I do have to say that it's
important that we reach out to our
physicians and this is one of the things
we're doing trying to do through public
service announcements our physicians
that are treating pelvic patients have
to be aware of where patients are in the
process that would make them eligible to
be good donors and people that think
they've had it or know they have had it
need to be able to reach out to their
blood bank through their physician and
go and have the plasma donated this is a
huge thing I can tell you three weeks
ago talking to my medical colleagues
saying if we had 55-gallon drums full of
IgG that's the antibody that you need we
could save a lot of people and what we
really want to do is make sure we can
get to people before they need a
ventilator and I think a lot of people
would step up and want to donate their
plasma if they know that they were able
to that's American right America steps
up to problems our people are great and
they just need to have the awareness so
thank you for pushing it out this
morning and we're going to continue to
push it out because it's extremely
important if we're going to proceed and
we'll save a lot of lives with this as
well I'm convinced good start
congressman
thank you very much thank you sir yeah
my pleasure good morning happy Easter
you tell happy